this is Jennifer's new
I can't erase the things I've done
there is no place left to run
life is hard
but it goes on
live my days as if they were my last
Jennifer candaus was reported missing in
1987. never been seen or heard from
since I'm Jennifer's brother I reached
out to an attorney about whether I could
sue my parents for the death of my
sister
for the first 22 years of her
disappearance everything I've been told
you know was was a lie
I thought at first she had run away and
that she didn't tell me and it's like
who is this person I think my mother
knows what happened he went two days to
call the police my father scared her to
keep this a secret so you really think I
did it yes
they both failed polygrass I want to
know the truth I cannot tell you
something I don't know
the story around Jennifer's
disappearance it doesn't make sense it
feels like you've convicted me of
something that I haven't done
this must be very emotional for you my
heart is racing a mile a minute
everybody has that case
that impact
thinking my parents were involved it's
made him question everything why are you
so consumed about this because it's only
right and she deserves better you think
it's crazy
all of a sudden it's even more crazy
[Music]
I'll never give up on Jennifer I just
have to keep on going